[Musique]
je
eric toledano bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté ce vip vous êtes
versaillais réalisateur co réalisateur
avec olivier nakache de films à succès
je vais en nommer quelques uns
nos jours heureux intouchable samba et
le récent sens de la fête
vous êtes ici avec nous dans le collège
raymond poincaré à versailles sur les
bancs de vaud de votre adolescence du
collège de votre adolescence parce que
vous avez répondu à l'appel de
l'association
un artiste à l'école donc nous avons la
joie de vous recevoir à cette occasion
pourquoi cette démarche
bon je trouve ça formidable de pouvoir
retourner un petit peu d'abord je pense
qu'on est toujours constitué un petit
peu de la ville d'où l'on vient et j'ai
grandi à versailles et alors si on est
constitué de la ville de lure bien les
expériences à l'intérieur de cette ville
le collège c'est quand même une période
très structurante dans la vie donc je
suis toujours curieux de revenir et de
mesurer un petit peu justement tout ce
qui s'est passé de revenir un petit peu
en introspection
je disais ça tout à l'heure j'ai
l'impression de revient dans le ventre
de ma mère voilà c'est c'est eh oui
parce que j'étais aussi les mâles cyrano
aversa et après je viens dans mon
collège
c'est une journée un petit peu voilà
dans la vie on se penche toujours vers
l'avenir vers le futur on regarde devant
de temps en temps un petit coup d'oeil
en arrière se passe pas plus mal non
plus ça permet de mieux voir l'avenir
aux cimes des codes se ressourcer
peut-être un peu voilà et dites moi ces
jeunes de 3e qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de leur dire en quelques mots j'ai
envie de leur donner un peu de
motivation
j'ai envie de nourrir un peu leurs
ambitions parce que parce que moi j'ai
fait l'expérience de d'un jeune qui
avait sûrement comme eux sur les bancs
de comme ça l'âge des petites et petites
rêve des petits voilà petit délire de
d'imagination et il se trouve que ça
peut être une source de quelque chose ça
peut être un chemin et je pense c'est
une période où on se questionne
énormément moi je me suis beaucoup
questionner cette période donc d'avoir
ce contact peut-être cette petit fils
invisibles que j'ai partagé le même
collège à une époque peut-être créer un
lien qui est difficile de créer avec
d'autres générations pour pouvoir
communiquer moi j'aime ce que je fais ce
métier pour essayer de communiquer le
maximum avec les gens donc quand on
m'invite généralement et que c'est
sympathique j'aime répondait c'est pas
la première fois d'ailleurs vous venez
nous l'annoncions maintenant et c'est
super ce que ça fait partie des rares
fois où j'ai posé la question à
l'intermédiaire quand est ce que c'est
oui j'ai un loyer ça j'avais envie
j'avais envie c'est chouette
est ce que ça vous paraît pas un peu
compliqué à l'heure actuelle de dire
tranquillement à des jeunes de 3e
allez-y tout est possible croyant vos
rêves le cinéma c'est possible c'est pas
plus con tu es pas dire ça comme ça et
leur dire ça différemment avec mes mots
à voix mais je pense non je pense pas
que ces croisières et je pense que vous
savez le film qu'on vient de faire le
sens de la fête ça s'appelait à la base
des temps difficiles et c'était pour
essayer de rigoler pour dire qui a
jamais eu autant facile alors quand on
regarde en arrière on se dit toujours
oui avant c'était plus simple en vérité
ça a toujours été compliqué c'est
toujours compliqué ça le sera toujours
donc il faut juste être combatifs et
voilà je vais essayer de le dire avec
mes beaux et en parlant de cinéma ce qui
est comme la chose qui me passionne le
belge imaginaire et j'ai vu dans fin
dans vos films vous avez comment dire
favoriser l'émergence d'acteurs au
départ pas forcément très connus alors
évidemment on m'a si il a démarré un peu
sa carrière en même temps que vous si je
puis dire
après je pense à tarime noces en bas je
pense à alban ivanov qui est un
humoriste versaillais voilà gens qui
jouent dans le sens de la fête qui a
pour la première fois un cylon rôle je
crois et jolis rôles
est ce que pour vous c'est important ce
fait de participer à l'émergence de
talents hammoud al hattar plus
qu'important c'est une responsabilité
quand on a un peu de lumière sur nous de
prendre tout pour soi et d'aller servir
chez les grands acteurs
oui oui c'est une tentation on l'a fait
et on le refera
de temps en temps aussi de pouvoir se
remettre dans la position où nous
n'avions pas la lumière et essayer de la
projeter essayer de faire des
découvertes et des rencontres avec des
gens qui ne sont pas encore passés c'est
aussi ce qu'a hydara dans le sens de la
fête qui joue l'assistant de jean pierre
bacri swiss et c'est toujours un
leitmotiv on aime se mélangent en fait
prendre des gens dont on a rêvé c'est
accéder à notre rêve et tendre la main
aussi à d'autres des nouveaux oui mais
ça fait une expérience la même somme à
rêves qu'on peut aller très loin
la preuve même choisi moi c'est fou et l
heure dite moi vous avez eu un parcours
un peu atypique parce que vous avez fait
des études de lettres option cinéma
d'accord vous avez fait de la défiance
politique
oui donc vous ne vous êtes pas dit tout
de suite je veux travailler dans le
cinéma vous n'avez pas fait d'école de
cinéma devez j'avais des parents qui
avait à coeur que je fasse des études
classiques et que le cinéma quand vous
dites à vos parents vous faire du cinéma
il ya un petit regard de compassion dans
l'oeil mais qui est gentil mais je
comprends j'aurai le même avec mes
enfants je suis passé et je dirais la
même chose que mes parents j'ai
structure ton esprit et quelques
cultures et après le cinéma c'est on
peut y arriver avec plein de moyens il
n'y a pas que les écoles de cinéma au
contraire parfois même c'est en fermant
mais c'est votre cas du coup parce que
vous avez démarré comme
assistant-réalisateur un petit peu oui
un petit peu mais pas beaucoup savent à
quoi beaucoup plus vous avez vous êtes
vite mis à l'action je crois ou les
collégiennes accalmie absolument métrage
voilà c'est ça est ce qu'on peut parler
du prochain film si prochain film il ya
oui il ya un prochain film qui
normalement devrait se tourner à la fin
de cette année et qui va un peu plus
proche d'un touche à leur raconter le
quotidien d'associations qui s'occupent
d'enfants autistes
ça va être un sujet qui sur le comme ça
a l'air un peu dur mais comme à
l'habitude et à l'accoutumée on va
essayer de mélanger le drame est aussi
une forme de légèreté qui permet
justement de mieux faire passer ce qu'on
a envie de raconter
d'accord mais écoutez génial donc le
prochain film qui sera sorti
vous savez à peu près quand un an 200
jours un an après voilà ce sera plutôt
pour l'année 2010 d'accord vous avez
déjà casting pas encore d'accord vous
aller mixer des stars et des oui il y
aura des gens plus reconnues et il y
aura beaucoup d'inconnues
beaucoup de nouveautés c'est un film
plus expérimental mais auquel j'ai
l'impression qu'olivier mois on a
quelque chose de très fort a raconté et
on espère y arriver c'est toujours le
défi on se remet en challenge c'est un
peu le c'est un peu le la difficulté de
ce métier c'est à dire qu'on revient
toujours à zéro il faut toujours
repartir dans la feuille blanche
mais cette fois ci on est très motivés
donc j'ai envie de dire même si c'est
pas le succès escompté ce concours parce
qu'on a toujours parce qu'on n'a jamais
jamais à l'avancé
voilà on a jamais de certitudes oui car
on a la certitude que c'est un sujet
dont on a envie de parler vous avez
envie absolue besoin est exactement
c'est la nécessité
vous êtes des terres et j'espère bon
écoutez je sais que vous êtes très
sensible aussi un bon aux jeunes de
troisième que vous allez rencontrer mais
aussi vous avez tourné un court-métrage
le bon vivant toujours avec olivier
nakache d'ailleurs pour patrick chesnais
fin l'association est ce court métrage
il est important aussi oui c'est en fait
on était très touché parce que patrick
chesnais a eu un drame dans sa vie c'est
qu'il a perdu son fils ferdinand à cause
de l'alcool au volant et du coup il
vient voir plusieurs réalisateurs c'est
guillaume canet avant nous il maïwenn
après et ils demandent si on peut écrire
un film essaie de sensibiliser de parler
à cette génération est effectivement
c'était très touchant et surtout je suis
très ému par l'idée que quelqu'un puisse
faire quelque chose de sa souffrance il
puisse construire quelque chose qui
puisse parler aux autres donc on l'a
fait et on était très fier de voir que
sur les réseaux et et dans le milieu
justement des gens que ça implique c'est
à dire les jeunes de 18 ans le film a
été beaucoup vu ça s'appelle le bon
vivant parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
parle face caméra et peut-être vous
mettrez en lien oui internationale ce
que ça c'est quelqu'un qui parle face
caméra il dit à quel point il aurait
aimé vivre plus longtemps mais que
parfois une petite erreur on n'a pas
vraiment l'impression que ça peut avoir
les conséquences mais c'est
disproportionné de mourir jeune comme ça
j'aime pas trop parler de ça mais mais
bon c'est vrai qu'avec mes potes je sais
très bien que c'est en train de vivre
des choses dont je m'en rappellerai
toute ma vie
pour moi c'était à refaire je ne
changerais rien mais je passe on
s'appelle de bain et au ça va et je vous
ai américain bisous enfin presque rien
donc oui c'était on a à coeur de toute
façon le milieu associatif
c'est quelque chose qui me touche le
sujet du prochain film
samba et précédente voilà était là tu
nous c'est sûr nos jours heureux dans
les colonies vacances on a fait nos
jours heureux pardon donc le groupe le
but le tout ce milieu là et et c'est
aussi pour ça que j'aime revenir quand
des associations comme un artiste à
l'école m'appelle parce que c'est un
monde duquel je viens je ce monde
associatif d'accord et vous garder le
lien j'essaye voilà alors merci eric
toledano merci à vous votre générosité
pour être ici dans ce collège et pour
tous les films que vous faites avec
olivier nakache gentil et qui nous font
un bien fou
ce parti a très vite mon séjour à tous
les gens de la région et murray a très
vite merci moi
[Musique]